uh today's uh press freedom day comes
as ukraine uh is under attack um i've
just gotten back from ukraine um there
are obviously a number of our colleagues
both ukrainian and non-ukrainian alike who
have lost their lives during this conflict
which for now shows no sign of ending on a
personal note i've just come here from the
cnn bureau i ran into the parents of austin tice
a fellow journalist who has been missing in syria
for the past almost 10 years he disappeared
in august of 2012. they are remarkable people
who are doing everything they can to bring their
son home it hits me particularly hard because i
used to cover syria and travel into syria doing
many of the same things that austin did when
he was when he was captured we often talk about
press freedom in the context of other countries
foreign countries beyond america but of course
we also have to consider what is happening here
in the united states in the time that
i've been back in the united states
i have had to deal with these issues up close i
was there at the capitol on january 6 when my team
and i were attacked uh verbally physically one
of my panelists and colleagues out here tonight
donio sullivan was also out there that was an
extraordinary moment in american history and
one that obviously has to be talked about in the
context of press freedom as well as i mentioned
in ukraine there's not just the physical war that
is happening there is also a disinformation war
that is very much underway uh that uh grew both in
the lead-up to that conflict um but also continues
today both inside ukraine where russia has tried
to get out their version of the facts and of
course inside russia where it is increasingly
difficult to get access to the truth where a
growing number of independent media outlets have
been shut down journalists have been arrested
and of course threatened and silenced so we're
going to be talking about all of that tonight
so with that i would like to bring out my
panelists for this evening the first is cnn's
donio sullivan he is a cnn correspondent
who covers the intersection of politics
and technology and the other is jason zion a
global opinion writer for the washington post
and the host of the spotify podcast 544 days
which chronicles the time that he spent jailed
in an iranian prison and what it took to get him
out so let's please give them a round of applause
so i'm just going to kick things off with a couple
questions for these guys and then we're going to
get to some of the questions that that you all
submitted and i'm really looking forward to this
discussion because these are two uh gentlemen
who who i respect enormously and who have done
such tremendous work over the past few
years jason i want to start with you
and and talk about what you've experienced
versus the moment that we're in right now
you recently wrote about russia's silencing
of journalists how in that silencing
disinformation arises can you compare what we
are seeing in russia right now the silencing
there with what you saw and experienced yourself
in iran which we so often talk about as an example
of a place that has no real free press so
thank you so much for the question alex and
i want to thank everybody for coming tonight um
today is world press freedom day but every day
should be world press freedom day it's that
important and i'm glad that people care so
good on you for being here with us rsf put out
their annual report press freedom index iran
ranks 178th out of 180 countries it's a horrible
place to be a journalist the only two that are
worse are eritrea and north korea but uh that
being said the disinformation that that russia
produces publishes broadcasts to its own
citizens makes what the iranians are able
to do pale in comparison because they are
so professional at creating false narratives
and unfortunately those false narratives have a
tendency of affecting how democracies functioning
democracies including our own operate so i would
say that that as horrible as my experience in iran
was as censored a media landscape as it is the
threat of russian disinformation and propaganda
is much greater than anything that the iranian
regime is able to um to create when you get a
sense that you're you're going to be under threat
because of what you're doing what you're reporting
um as you feel you know things closing
in around you in terms of the authorities
what does that feel like how do you balance your
need and desire to get the news out what you're
reporting versus your your own personal safety
so you know i i lived and worked in iran for five
years before i was arrested with full permission
of the iranian state i understood very well
what the red lines were what i could and could not
safely report on where i could and could not go
here in the united states and in western
europe and in democratic countries
you're not going to make those kinds of
compromises as a journalist that you know
okay i'm not allowed to report on this so i'm not
going to report on them but in a place like iran
you understand that it's the difference between
one having your ability to operate in that country
taken from you two potentially your freedom
um and so you know news organizations whether
it's the washington post cnn new york times and a
whole host of others make a calculation that it's
better to have feet on the ground in those places
reporting to a limited extent rather than being
shut out entirely for those of us who live and
work in those kind of atmospheres the the stress
level is constant but it's always at a low hum
for me in the days and weeks ahead of my arrest
it was starting to build you know first it was
hacks into my social media and email accounts
next it was being followed around uh tehran the
city where i lived and and worked until finally
my wife and i were arrested at gunpoint in our
home hauled off to prison handcuffed blindfolded
and thrown into solitary confinement accused
of spying for the u.s government and really
thrown into a state of shock that now almost eight
years later is just starting to dissipate so i i
think you have to steal yourself and prepare
yourself to work in those kinds of countries
in the same way that you do when you walk into
a conflict zone which you know all too well
the threats are very real but we make the decision
that doing this work is that important and
uh and we're committed to doing it uh dhoni
focuses as many of you know on a lot of the
disinformation um in this country um a lot
of what happens on social media platforms
as i mentioned dhoni was
also out there on january 6th
he travels all around the country speaking
to people about a whole range of issues
i want to show a quick clip of some of his work
and then we'll get to ask him some questions
it's been a year since the
attack on the us capital
and because of disinformation denial and diversion
americans don't have a shared history a shared
understanding of what happened here on that
day i think the whole reporting of it is a
giant hoax we are very peaceful people so it was
a total setup to me it was the fbi had set it up
i don't believe that they were trump supporters
that did that you said the whole thing's a setup
you don't really believe that do you i do i
do because trump won the election they they
they've proven it over and over again i spoke to
trump supporters at two recent events held by the
former president in florida i think that it was
set up and i think that people didn't know what
was happening and i think that they went in there
and they were caught in a trap if you will you're
suggesting that january 6 was was a setup yes i
am but you would acknowledge there was there was
a lot of trump supporters
involved in the violence that day
i didn't see any trump supporters in the violence
i saw people that pretended to be trump supporters
in that violence wild things i i think when
we talk about the timeline of disinformation
in this country a lot of people look to 2016
and what the russians did in that election
um so much of what we see now here in terms of
disinformation is domestically produced it's
as if americans took that russian playbook
um and and sort of ran with it um so you go
out and you speak with people who believe all
kinds of things a lot of which are not founded
um in in any real truth so what do you see as
as your as your mission or what you're trying to
accomplish through your reporting yeah i mean i've
spent uh i guess seven years now covering online
misinformation um and disinformation uh and for
the most of that time i spent it covering it from
behind a computer screen as most misinformation
com reporters do um and it was during it was
actually when our colleague jim acosta uh was
out at one trump rally in the summer of 2020 i
think it was when trump started doing rallies
again and it was a partially indoor rally and
people weren't wearing masks and i think jim was
asking people you know why aren't you wearing a
mask and a lot of people started saying i there is
no covert this is all hoax etc etc and that's when
i started asking my bosses to say look i really
want to go and ask the follow-up question to say
where are you getting this information not
only to do that but just to have people
and and many trump supporters have opened their
facebook feeds for me and show me uh where they
are getting this information this misinformation
disinformation um so for me i mean i'm just kind
of fascinated by how people arrive as uh the
conclusions they arrive at and figuring out where
in their information uh diet that a lot of this
junk is coming from and i think you know you kind
of see in those clips there look some people we
speak to kind of know better and people have of
course their biases and they want to believe
what they want to believe and some people know
um that you know what they're saying about
january 6 no trump supporters being there is a lie
and it's a political talking point but other
people i meet genuinely really really believe that
you are almost certainly not going to get
arrested for what you do in this country
and uh if you haven't seen it already trevor
noah gave a terrific speech about this at the
white house correspondents dinner this past
weekend um but there is certainly hostility
towards many in the press uh in the us
and and in particular at cnn and some of
the places that that you go to um how do you
how do you confront that hostility how do you
how do you manage it um what's your what's your
approach um well the irish accent helps for sure
no i've been on a serious note i will say
we have found ourselves in some sticky
situations obviously january 60 you knowing
better than anyone else really with that but
um you know i have found for the most part we i i
approach these conversations um with transporters
and that i genuinely want to figure out what it
is they believe and why they believe it um and try
not to speak down to anyone you know i genuinely
want to figure out why they arrive at this point
and you know we we do a lot of these stories and
a lot of people on the left will say oh my god you
know you've exposed them for being fools etc etc
but i've stayed in touch with quite a few of the
people we've interviewed and um they say okay
well you said what i was saying was false you
explained it was misinformation but they said well
we kind of expect that but we're they're thankful
that we've made the effort to come and speak to
them to not cut up their clips in a way that's
you know misrepresents what they say and
that we've kind of made the effort to
travel to the back end of alabama on a saturday
afternoon to speak with somebody in a field for
25 or 30 minutes so they're generally happy with
the way that you portray them and yeah i mean um
you know they certainly you know they certainly it
doesn't change their world view i don't think um
but i don't really view that as my role leader i
my role as a reporter is to go and find out what
you know in this case what people believe why
they believe us and and to to share that story
jason um you know you were you were in in iran
and i spent a lot of time covering the middle
east as well and i think uh in places like
that people do go to um very specific places
to get their information um those those
silos um which we're are seeing more of
these days what what do you make of the landscape
now in the united states in terms of how people
are uh getting and digesting their information
well i think it mimics a a lot of what's been
happening in the middle east and and other uh
countries that have been moving in authoritarian
directions especially long established democracies
like india like the philippines where um
you know facebook and other social media
platforms have become the main source of
news for people and without any kind of regulation
any sort of information that one wants to publish
can be disseminated and as dhoni has seen that's
starting to happen here in the united states as
well i don't think we're immune to any of it and
so for me when i write stories about the u.s now
i always think that my um my reporting skills
and and uh resources that i learned as a foreign
correspondent are as applicable here in the united
states in a different kind of way than than they
would have been before and i i would you know
say that anybody that's looking to cover the us
and politics in the u.s and different communities
here should take take that approach to it you know
definitely not talk down to people but at the same
time really trying to hear them out what's going
on and um although it might be impossible to put
oneself uh in the shoes of somebody who believes
that sort of misinformation this information
you got to try um i want to get to some of the
audience questions and this one is from
lizzie and dhoni to you first we spend so
much time discussing especially in light of this
recent percher purchase soon to be purchased of
twitter by elon musk and and how he
would see the regulation of of that
platform lizzie wants to know what direction
would you like to see platform regulation go
as it relates to journalism in particular um
i certainly wouldn't be qualified to write
the regulations but what i would say is um you
know even without laws and regulations but it's
becoming more and more clear that there has to be
something because these platforms seemingly won't
act otherwise is you know um there's a lot to be
said for and elon musk has actually been saying
that elon musk has been saying a lot of crazy
stuff uh but he's also been making some points in
roundabout ways that are that are helpful in that
and they're to have some degree of transparency
about the algorithms right because we like it's
still it's still a black box we don't know really
what makes stuff go crazy on on facebook and
what way facebook is pushing this content right
and facebook will roll out many explanations
and they'll say we're doing x and y and z
but then every time you log on to the platform
you know if it was francis haugen that the
facebook whistleblower uh revealed documents
that facebook's own research internally
found i think they set up an account to look
like a mom in south carolina north carolina
and liked a few conservative pages like
the q and on pager two and all of a sudden
the fate it was facebook recommending to that
person more q and on content bringing them in
down further and further down the rabbit hole
so transparency i think about that um i don't
think and not necessarily there ever should be
government regulation um on these tech platforms
about speech obviously that would would
go against the first amendment but i do
think the smart conversation we had is about the
amplification on the platforms jason yeah yeah i
wanted to also add though that i think that there
does need to be much more effort and care put into
upholding the rules and regulations of the
platforms especially around hate speech and libel
i mean i i consistently continue to get
accused of being a spy for the us government
by iranian twitter and that's not true that's
never been founded that it's sully's my reputation
you know there's nothing i can do about it when
i report these tweets absolutely nothing happens
the response is always twitter has you
know deemed this in compliance with our
our our norms they've got to get much better at
that one of the things that i've heard that elon
musk has been talking about also is the idea
of making every account a verified account
right attaching it to an actual human person
um i think maybe that's not a bad idea
more complicated than than it sounds probably uh
but there is a lot of work to be done and i think
while i agree that you know the fundamental
principle of free expression has to be um
cherished and and respected we can't let people
take advantage of it to propagate hate crime and
other forms of of libel against people and just
piggyback on those two points um you know you're a
high-profile journalist one of the biggest
newspapers in the world for many people
especially women on the platform who are just
private citizens when they get harassed they
have absolutely no recourse at all whatsoever and
i do think and believe me we're not i am not on
an elon musk bandwagon here he is you can see on
his twitter he is flirting with the alt-right and
saying really quite um worrying things but on
the point of um verifying users on a platform
so many people i have spoken to who want to engage
especially women online politic in political
discourse they feel like they can't because
there's so many anonymous trolls pushing them off
but so when you come to that free speech argument
uh there is something there that i think could be
remedied by having people verify who they are when
you guys look at social media do you look at it as
you know as a are they all lumped together or are
there companies that are doing more than others
donate you first um definitely i mean that the
companies kind of vary and even within facebook
there are teams that do good work and there are
teams that kind of deflect facebook has a pretty
good team now after 2016 when they had no idea
that russia was running a disinformation campaign
um posing as americans and they kind of got on
that and they have a team now that that is you
know revealing a lot of these state-backed in iran
ii um campaigns um but certainly the platforms
vary uh day-to-day i would say twitter normally
has been a little bit more transparent but
it ebbs and flows um and also then there's the
bigger point of which gets very we don't cover it
enough frankly is you know we talk a lot about the
open platforms but of course then there's spaces
like whatsapp where there are family groups or
there are bigger groups with dozens or maybe
up to 250 people or so and a lot of stuff
gets disseminated in there and that there's
there's there's no kind of recourse for that at
the moment it's all important or telegram as well
which you know which can have much larger so many
so many of the us conservatives and the alt-right
moved to telegram after january 6th here when they
got quote-unquote d-platform from from the likes
of twitter and it's a worrying trend when you know
that that's the preferred platform of russians
iranians and chinese jason but but speak to the
you know overseas and it's been in particular in
places where there's only state media or and
there's no real independent media people are
much more reliant on the social media platforms
in order to get the actual news well which makes
it that much more essential for some sort of
regulation i mean i think these ecosystems
are so vast and hard to monitor hard to control
and then bring in the fact that you have um
communities in literally hundreds of different
languages right yeah there aren't teams
at facebook and twitter monitoring the content
of every single language out there that's just
not feasible it should be but it isn't um and
i think that you know for the the sake of uh
healthy news consumption we have to figure all
of this out but it's not happening and i think
that the the ways that that misinformation and
disinformation are being spread and amplified um
are are incredibly concerning i will say that
you know not to totally pile on the platforms
uh you know one effort that facebook did make and
put in a lot of money was um hiring independent
fact checkers third party fact checkers they've
you know they've hired tons here in the us
they work with the likes of reuters politifacts
many other outlets and they've done it globally
and when they really started rolling this out i
guess around maybe 20 20 or so maybe before that
but um you know we kind of covered it in the
technology press as like they're doing this
thing you know it's gonna if you share something
that's false facebook might label it with a fact
check and say here's the real information um i
was stunned when i would start going out into the
field and asking people at trump rallies about
facebook everybody on the tip of their tongue
had these fact checkers they were like oh yeah
my stuff gets labeled all the time as false
but they were talking about the fact checkers
in the way that the kind of mainstream media
has been demonized but that demonization happens
so quickly and you know for many of the folks
these fact checks something that says well what
you've shared here is faults whether it's false
claims about the electron kind of became badges of
honor uh it was gamified so you know even when the
platforms try to make an effort possibly with some
of the target audience it gets flipped on its head
jason and we are obviously at university and and
in a school of media and i think many of you are
probably interested in going into this industry
and one of our audience members has asked whether
the growing number of journalists captured or
killed overseas has had an impact on people
choosing to follow this career path and i would
just follow that up with asking should it have an
impact look i mean i think it it certainly should
have an impact um in my skewed point of view as
somebody who was a journalist who was imprisoned
abroad for a long period of time it's made me
want to double down on this profession and i
think it's an important calling and if people
feel pulled towards telling stories of communities
and places that they may or may not have access to
or would like to know more about or believe are
underrepresented that's a noble thing to do i
think it certainly had an impact i will say though
that you know the three of us have been in very
difficult reporting situations um i can only speak
for myself but i i never wake up in the morning
and want to go out and get into trouble or
get hurt or see somebody else get hurt right
that's not why we do this it's not for uh
sensationalizing the the strife and hardship
it's for getting information out to people that
they wouldn't otherwise have access to um and
in a lot of ways i think we are witnessing some
of the best journalism ever right now in different
formats different ways of storytelling
that didn't exist previously my concern is
unfortunately it's maybe having less of an impact
than than it did in the past so that's a kind
of a strange dichotomy that the work that's
coming out right now is so damn good um but
uh there's so many competing platforms ideas
points of view and people attacking what we do
um that it's not having the same kind of impact
that it should donate you raised this earlier um
you know you're speaking with people who who
aren't necessarily going to believe what you
tell them so to jason's point even if you've got
some terrific journalism out there do you believe
that um some are lost how do you break through
yeah it's pretty disheartening you know um and
i would say that that i often see times too when i
just share on my twitter feed maybe reporting from
our white house correspondents of something
when biden messes up or something the white
house might have not done right today um i'll have
liberal followers democrats tweeting me sometimes
quite vile stuff attacking me for saying why are
you sharing why why are you attacking biden um
so i i certainly think the issue is far more
pronounced in the us at the moment than the right
but because there is such polarization and
because in the world of twitter and online
people get into their camps uh people on
on the other side of the isle too are being
i think programmed almost into thinking no we only
want to also consume the news we want to hear and
that i think is that's it's messed up to you know
alex and i grew up at a time in this country when
um households oftentimes still got two
newspapers right uh so that you knew
yeah exactly three tv channels
they had tv back when you were here
alex is actually this anti-aging cream but you
know the idea was that you wanted to know what
what people that didn't think like you do think
we don't want that anymore right we want to be
uh validated for our our points of view um
and choosing to try and understand um how
other people think that are that are different
than us takes a real discipline that i think
has has been uh dissipating in in recent years
and i think a function of that has to do with
um with how social media sort of rewards us for
um creating content that other people applaud
and it's not just us in in the media right you
know a lot of people out there are like hunters
right and uh and i'm not talking only about young
people or middle-aged people you know people
across the spectrum everybody wants to believe
that their point of view is valuable and and um
has support and unfortunately i i think we
have to extricate ourselves from that and
that's going to be a hard thing to do i want to
go back to this question about personal safety
january 6 was one day and i think no matter how
long i'm a journalist it's going to go down as
one of the most extraordinary moments that i've
ever covered and you know i i knew that there was
going to be some animosity towards journalists in
general and perhaps cnn in particular that day so
i kind of kept my distance early on in the in what
was then still a protest and then as it turned
into a full-blown riot i got a little bit closer
my team and i got closer and that's when they
figured out who we were they turned around
and turned on us and i think what was most
jarring and shocking was that this was not
something that that i was covering um overseas
where i'd been in plenty of hairy situations and
uprisings but it was in the town that i live in
um getting screamed at and threatened saying
things like we will effing destroy you um in
english and you know in in my mother tongue um
and then to leave at the end of the day and take a
cab and go five minutes home was uh it was it was
really just extraordinary and i ran into dhoni at
the end of that day and um actually did something
that wasn't very cool i had a hat on and i was you
know big jacket i had a mask as well and i went
right up to him and i could have been anybody
and i could see this sort of alarm in his eyes i
had forgotten about that so thanks yeah that was
great but that's a very long way of of asking i
think so much of the country was shocked by that
day a year and a bit later a lot of the country
now is downplaying the importance of that day
but doni you you travel around this country more
than than either jason or i do for work do you
think that hostility towards the press is has
got is getting worse yeah i mean i think that
look i think like the the the kind of uh chance
sometimes that and people say to my face you know
we go to trump rallies and there's a lot of people
who tell us f write off don't want to talk to us
and that's fine then there's other people who will
do these trump sponsored chanters you know cnn
sucks but then they'll have a conversation with
you um and you kind of realize that that for a lot
of folks that this it's all a bit of theater and
they don't take it as seriously they'll still have
a conversation with us they still might even watch
cnn um but there obviously is plenty of folks that
that take it to the extreme i mean the guy who
sent mail bombs to to to cnn the people that you
encountered on january 6 and also our colleagues
ellie reeve and others um but i think those
there's something to be said for for the people
in the middle the people who kind of view it as a
joke um but still show up uh that's that's the
kind of that's the mob mentality that is the
that's the masses that showed up on january 6 the
kind of physical manifestation of the online mob
it's those people that sort of say oh you know
cnn sucks but maybe they won't necessarily act
but they kind of allowed you know the the real
instigators of the violence they gave them cover
and they allowed them to move into the capital the
people standing out on the lawn and many people
who were on the lawn that day out on the streets
didn't wouldn't commit violent acts themselves
but they certainly were quite sympathetic
to maybe some of the people who accosted you
um so i think that's kind of like where
they're you know that i find a little um
you know in some ways almost more disturbing
than the guys who go right for the violence it's
it's the people the very kind of normal
people and people that you'd have living on
your street people who could be in your family
or cousins uh that's kind of just not giving
a damn about a lot of this stuff you know yeah
it is important to note that diversity i mean
certainly there are all kinds of people who are
out there that day some who just you know we're
taking it all in um i've been to trump rallies
where same thing i've waded through the crowd
and people would come up and say hi and i think
if our colleague jim acosta were here tonight
he'd tell you about all the selfies that he's
taking at trump rallies because people love to
talk to him and and say hi and um and and you know
they love the sort of back and forth that he's had
with with former president trump um jason back
to you know sort of younger people and getting
into this industry um krupal crew yes kruple
uh i assume as a student here wants advice on
how people get into storytelling through
interviewing and especially here in dc
and i would again add something how would
you get into it given the sheer number of
outlets these days yeah well i think first
of all you're at a wonderful institution for
learning the the best skills i was a turker
fellow here a couple of years ago i actually
lived on campus right here on 21st street for two
years and it was an amazing experience in that
i got to engage with with students from all
over the country and all over the world who were
hungry to to learn but also to engage and i think
you've got the greatest classroom in the world
right outside your doors here in washington
dc but also in the surrounding area you have
communities of uh immigrant populations from
all over the world right so you know i i i often
like to get out and talk to people
who come from parts of the world
that i know nothing about you know these days
with the war in ukraine i'm seeking out ukrainians
to talk to to get to get their perspective people
that live locally than people that that have been
passing through recently also afghan journalists
who've been you know exiled and are now living
in the united states i spent a lot of time talking
with them and i also think just honing your skills
first and foremost as observers and listeners
right um frank cessno who was a professor here
and was the director at snpa for a lot
of years used to teach a class and in
in interviewing skills and um you know i think
the most important thing that i learned from
sitting in on that class was just listening
right and it's not something that uh
in this media landscape in this political
landscape we are being um encouraged to do
and i want to give you all the uh the
encouragement to do that listen better
dona you have a great origin story how you got
to cnn um because you were a big fan of cnn's
when you were outside the company and now you're
one of the company's biggest rising stars so how
did you get your start and and similarly what what
advice would you give um yeah i mean i was always
kind of obsessed with social media and i worked
with a lucky i got an internship at a company
called story full um when i got out of college
was an irish company that verifies the videos and
images that pop up on social media during breaking
news and cnn eventually hired me to do that and
somebody put me on television at some point i
think that person probably now fired or something
but they should be at least no but i would say in
terms of um talking to people i mean i was outside
the supreme court today and um you know there's
plenty of people there with megaphones and people
you know who are coordinated with t-shirts and
people who who are you know part of groups and
very able and willing to speak um but i normally
like to talk to the folks who were kind of on the
sidelines uh you know people who were have kind
of come to have a look and maybe have brought a
homemade sign or maybe it's their they're not
these kind of you know they're they don't go
protest every day um and i think they're the
people you find the most uh interesting stories
from um and then as as jason said i mean just
willing to listen and giving people time to talk
and not just waiting um you know not trying to
pressure somebody into just saying what you want
to file that's going to fit the story you have
in your head but let's see how it goes and i
think just giving people time um and i will say
don't ever do the annoying thing which happened to
me today was when i was speaking to somebody who
was great and then another journalist by saw that
we were getting good stuff it just came right
up to her after we spoke to her don't do that
um but or maybe two uh you know you gotta do what
you gotta do but yeah it is listening to people
yeah it really is um i wanna get back to some
of the student questions this is from a student
a researcher who's studying q and on and stop the
steal um lorcan i believe is your name i'm sorry
i can't read it um but this this balance whether
it's here domestically or overseas jason how do
we cover and hold extremist groups accountable
through journalism without giving these same
actors uh oxygen in the mainstream press that
could help their cause well that's that's an
incredible question that i don't think we've
come up with a good answer for yet um you know
by simply calling them out and writing uh about uh
misinformation and and kind of conspiracy theories
you're inevitably repeating that uh
that problem and giving it a a new
life i've been following the case of um
a slight tangential shift but of brittany
greiner the wnba basketball player who's being
held in in russia i don't talk about the charges
against her when i write about her
when i speak about her on television
simply because the act of repeating charges
that have not been uh substantiated not been
verified i'm doing the russians job for them and
that's from a sovereign government that's not
a you know marginalized exactly as of today this
afternoon the state department said that brittany
griner is being wrongfully detained by the russian
government that's a political euphemism for being
for being held hostage right um so you know i i
think that it's really important that we'd be very
cautious when we call these things out um i think
you know labeling misinformation disinformation
conspiracy theories when we report on them has
to be more pronounced and more uh visible um
but unfortunately we can't just ignore these
things out of existence so i don't know i'd
like to hear what what tony has to think yeah i
mean it's the question we kind of deal with every
day i mean i would say that you know i followed q
anon for a very long time as part of my job but we
never reported on it for years um you know started
in 2017 and we're keeping an eye on it and i speak
pretty much every day with our standards team and
for a very long time even throughout a lot of 2020
um you know q anon would come up different stories
and i would say i you know i i'm still not sure
this seems just so crazy unhinged that i don't
know i don't think we need to report on it and
then you know lo and behold in the space of a few
weeks you saw trump kind of winking and nodding
at us at a nbc town hall in the weeks before the
election and um and i think i was wrong frankly in
terms of being uh say you know i i think i let it
kind of go to the point where maybe we should we
should have called it out earlier uh but you know
it's very difficult to get to to get those things
right i think to what jason says is you know
what we try and do in our reporting is we try to
kind of make a fruit sandwich you know to tell
the person at the beginning by the way the next
paragraph the belief that they have is bs and
then kind of reminding the person again after it
uh but you ultimately i guess you are platforming
them in some way and sometimes these groups when
they see they're being covered by the mainstream
media they use us as a weapon again to say you
know see they're saying this so we must be right
but that i don't think should be a reason that we
shouldn't report on it because you know you'd
never report on anything then i guess we only
have a couple minutes left um so i want to ask you
both um you know i think on on world press freedom
day um in the midst of a war in ukraine it's very
it's it's very easy to note the importance of the
press and you know why we do this and why people
want to get into this industry um but at the same
time we are uh in difficult times in the press in
terms of the the faith that the audience has in
us um and you know a lot of that really comes to
for during a political year which this is so jason
what work do you think that we can do to regain
some of the trust that we've lost from from the
audience so one of the things that that i've
been noticing um in the attacks on journalists
in the united states and other countries is
a real dehumanizing element right um the the
way that we are talked about on social media
uh in some horrific cases the way journalists
have been murdered um and there's almost never
any accountability uh in these cases we don't
deserve that that's not anything that anybody
should should have to face but i think that we as
journalists have to do a better job of maintaining
our own sense of humanity and that of the stories
that we cover right something that dhoni talked
about earlier i mean i think the the the folks
at some of these political rallies just want to
be taken seriously right and i think that that
it's incumbent on us to hear people out to report
on what it is that they see happening in the world
whether it's accurate or not um and and and
and maintain lines of communication because
if we don't we're in for even more trouble don't
need any advice um i guess just really echoing uh
what jason said is that uh you know so many i
think there can be a tendency sometimes when
um you know reporters in dc or new york go out uh
into the country uh it's almost described in ways
as if it's you know david attenborough ex you know
uh yeah and it's it's um it's like you know we're
all just we're we are all people at the end of the
day without sounding too cliche and cheesy about
it um and i think i i do think a lot of it is how
reporters approach uh parts that might not be the
metropolitan areas and things like that about how
you approach talking to people how you approach
covering it and kind of just you know trying to
not don't look down your nose at anyone absolutely
um on that note we have to leave it there thank
you both for your thoughts your insights for
you all for coming out tonight i would ask
if you're interested you can you can register
for more of these virtual events and when
we have them in person as well at cnn.com
backslash citizen we will be holding another
one tomorrow afternoon 2 pm eastern time
that topic is roe vs wade what happens
next thanks so much for coming out